brothers
god
may love you
but does he like you
all righty your transcript and your
application to graduate thank you
your scholarship expired last semester
i'm gonna pour you a drink
hold on hold on we have decided to give
tonight's offering towards our
missionaries and their efforts why do
people go to charity events because they
want to help people wrong because they
want to feel like they're helping people
excuse me could you just tell me he's
running this event praise god thank you
all so much for coming out kenhub
executive director cross country i have
every intention of putting you on the
national stage wow
i'm curious we would love to hear more
about your work in lesotho ah
yeah uh i mean
this is really the lord's work wouldn't
you say
amen
amen
you guys are the guys hey we're the guys
fellas this must be the god squad hey
sam how are you gabriel my friends call
me gabriel but uh let's keep it at
gabriel for now
i mean do you think he still wakes up
watching vh1
because the goo-goo don't
well
we might be a little in over our heads
yeah we're gonna need a bigger bag
i propose we start a clothing line and
we're gonna call it
you